ever blundered made in one
I the game once where I was calculating
a variation where I had May than one it
was like five moves deep but I didn't
see the main one so I didn't play the
variation it would have been completely
winning and I went on to draw the game
okay I'm deserting we're gonna be
aggressive find win quickly I do this
you
[Music]
resign now you are going to lose to the
sky
well I did I could say that
that's so pessimistic
I'm playing the Budapest making the
fucsia happy
have to play ambitiously
I highly recommend the London that's my
favorite opening ever
it's even more of a favorite than the
Budapest
I don't think this variation is bad for
whites a lot of people walk into it
without knowing anything
is it really called the Adler variation
and I'm not that knowledgeable about
like the theory but I know I know the
ideas this being the main idea all Fiats
chess
and I'm pretty sure I've had this
position many times before
and neither 94 is a good move I play
Bishop f8
I still want to bring the rook over
Nathan after sharing the London video
um 5.9 g6 and just have some type of
skewer
you
he's playing quickly
or playing decent moves
just a little bit unsettling f5 work
here
we'll be doesn't work
you
a four
question is is he threatening at 5f 6
because that's the possibility but
probably not because I have just 95 I'm
gonna play a four
not sure if that accomplishes anything
but
hopefully it makes them think
he's gaining time he's gained time
almost every move c5
retreats
that I don't have this rip lived any
more
you
we're what
Oh night pot
Lynx
but if you want to share a link
you have to be a mod to share a link I
guess
it's possible that that last person used
an engine I think he just left and
that's why I was able to claim victory
but I don't know
okay now can I just take care
take care
Bishop takes e5
five
it's scary
each six Bishop tg6
maybe I just play h6 right away
or even f6 f6 could be a move that walks
them to Bishop c4 though
okay squinty tribes the major threats
a problem with h6 isn't I take f7 Bishop
c4 that's crazy
so he has two threats here in 1907 and
Queen h5i g5 such a strong move
what do I do
I'd probably have to go for the slime
Bishop takes e5 when h5 h6 he takes on
f7 I think it's just lost already he's
just
played brilliantly
so taxi
give ratings as half ratings
you
three Queenie seven when you sevens a
try threatening to take on e3
let's do it
don't see anything else
you
you
I'm not comfortable here
he's playing this a lot better than most
players like is harmony among the pieces
it's frightening
but at least he's thinking
Oh
you
I'm curious I have not been really
following the connect the new commands
which had been created Bishop c4
and defend with taking on e3 and rookie
I have 9h8 to if completely necessary
out of a sad move though
take on e3
why not Bishop c4 is so bold it's like
no fear
ah so unpleasant he's just crushing me
any rookie seven
you
brookey southern
ah rookie you know what happens maybes
defy of them
d5 and then Bishop e6 what else to do
you
you
he has a winning move here by the way
I think he's going to play it
players a that's going to be very sad
Queen age 5 at callosity winning thank
you whatever your name is for the follow
claw clasp Farah - interesting name
after play h6
or do I have the ship take now fish at
86 doesn't work
you
it's been a while since I've gotten
crushed this bad
like okay queen b1 was disappointing
last game but this is just I'm yet just
getting completely outplayed
okay I can take care maybe survive a bit
longer
maybe not
perky five maybe
g6 is going to be hanging
quickly that's a scary thing
you
what do I do
wait it's equal material Mike what's
about to fall but he's just winning
material then
okay I'm just gonna play this outing
because I want to see how he converts
sedessa move to fly on
normally I would just resign but
what's the best move to fly on
neither for yeah let's confuse him I'll
see if he gets confused
yeah he's averaging like below 10
seconds to move
you
doesn't pay too much blitz
that's crazy
well if he's 1700 in classical hopefully
it shows at some points
you
you
staying alive
you
waitwhat
okay
oh I guess that's so funny
I wish okay I wish I plated a different
opening I would have enjoyed playing a
game it's someone like this but what to
do this is so funny
lady taxi southern
girls play a three I hope you take c7
this is why I'm playing on cuz I'm just
I'm fascinated with how
certain types of players can read
positions
opposite there
I'm just a bishop before
you
all it's gonna take is one slip
you
move
what to you I think that what Center is
on
just looking for a line which would like
comped another computer move
you
okay I'm not gonna waste any more time
in this game uh let's just take the
bishop and he's gonna admit me but he's
gonna think before he meets me
yes okay back to tournament well that
was disappointing